كانت ويتني دوان وزوجها
آنذاك ديزموند شوم من النجوم الصاعدة في
عالم الأعمال في الصين ، لكن بعد أن
غادر الشام البلاد اختفى دوان
دون أن يترك أثراً ،
لم يسمع أحد بكلمة منها
لسنوات حتى يوم السبت
وفقًا لشوم ، اتصلت به وتوسلت
إليه.  لا ينشر كتابه الجديد ، الذي
يعد بسحب الستار عن
الصين الصينية ، كانت المكالمة متأخرة جدًا
بالطبع ، لقد تم طباعة الكتاب بالفعل
، وهو بعنوان الروليت الأحمر ،
وينضم إلي ديزموند شوم الآن في أول
مقابلة تلفزيونية له وهو في أكسفورد
إنجلترا  ديزموند شارم ، مرحبًا بك في
البرنامج
الآن ، لا بد أن هذه المكالمة التي تلقيتها خلال عطلة نهاية
الأسبوع كانت مقلقة للغاية
خاصةً لأنك تعلم أنك
كنت تستعد للقيام بالدعاية
لنشر كتبك ،
ما رأيك في جوهر المشكلة لماذا؟
فجأة ظهرت زوجتك السابقة بعد أربع
سنوات من العدم
بشكل جيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء شكرًا
لاستضافتي أعتقد أن ما حدث كان يوم الجمعة.
تحتوي كل من الأوقات المالية في الصحف الرئيسية في
مجلة وول ستريت على
قصة كاري من
كتابي القادم وأه حالتي
أعتقد أن هذا حقًا
غير الديناميكيات ثم دفعها في
الواقع إلى
أن حدث ما حدث في اليوم التالي لكتابي.
كتاب جريدة كسر القصص ،
فماذا كانت رسالتها لك
لم تتصل بها فقط لتقول مرحباً
، يبدو أن ccp لم تكن مسرورة
لأنك تعرف أن زوجها السابق
على وشك نشر كتاب أه
يقول إن أممم تكشف كثيرًا في  بالطريقة التي
قصدوا أنها قد لا
تستخدمها ، كما تعلمون ، من الصعب جدًا ،
أعني أنها تريدني أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أنها
تريد مني إلغاء الكتاب الذي
نشره
الكتاب بالطبع كما
ذكرت للتو في البيروقراطيين في بكين ، ربما
تعتقد ذلك  إصبع سريع يمكن لأي كتاب أن
يثبت من أي مكتبة في أي
وقت بالطبع في عالمنا أن الكتاب موجود
بالفعل في المكتبات بحلول ذلك الوقت
ومن ثم يصعب عليّ أيضًا
لأنني لا أعرف
من أعرف من لا أعرفه  لا أعرف من أتحدث إليه
لأنه من
المؤكد أن هاتفها يخضع للمراقبة
إذا لم يكن هناك شخص يجلس مقابلها
وأنا أتحدث معها أو
أتحدث إلى الطرف الذي يتخلف عن
الاستماع في
مطالبتي بإلغاء الكتاب و  إصدار
جميع التهديدات ،
لذا فإن التهديدات هي ما أعتقد أنه
يهمني ويثير اهتمام الكثير من الناس
ومن الواضح أنه يجب أن تقلقك يا
ابنك وزوجتك السابقة
هل شعرت أنها كانت تستخدم
لتهديدك ،
هل قالت أنه ستكون هناك
عواقب عليك  بالنسبة لابنك ، إذا
استمر هذا الكتاب ،
فأنا بالتأكيد أعني
أنني أشعر
وكأنها لسان حال إقامة الحفلة
وتهددني ، فأنت تعلم رسالة تسأل فيها عما
سيحدث لابننا إذا حدث لك شيء
، لقد سألت  تساءل عما يمكن أن يحدث
لك إذا حدث شيء
ما لابننا
، ثم في الدورة الثانية ،
ستقول في الواقع
إذا واصلت إطلاق هذا الكتاب ،
فقد يتسبب ذلك في حياة ،
لذلك طرحت السؤال هو  إنه
ديفيد شارما ، إنه أمر مخيف حقًا
إنه سؤال صالح لحياته
تقشعر لها الأبدان